aujourd'hui le gouvernement du Québec
préserve le service de garde à
contribution réduite au Québec plutôt
que d'assister passivement à son
effritement le Premier ministre ce matin
et son gouvernement ont annoncé une
nouvelle taxe famille pour la classe
moyenne honnêtement monsieur le
Président c'est une trahison que vivent
les Québécois et les familles ce qu'on
voit encore une fois c'est que Philippe
Couillard respecte pas ses
promesses forte réaction de l'opposition
aujourd'hui mais l'état des finances
publiques au Québec nécessite des
compressions budgétaires la fin du tarif
unique dans les services de garde va
renflouer les coffres de 160 millions de
dollars par année alors s'attaquer au
garderie est-ce vraiment la bonne cible
tacha est ce soir à Toronto bonsoir
tacha bonsoir et Michel et Daniel sont
avec moi en studio bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir alors avant de parler de la
question de fond Philippe Couillard en
campagne oral avait promis de ne pas
augmenter les tarifs de Gard on se
souvient qu'il avait beaucoup critiqué
la proposition du Parti québécois de
faire passer ce tarif de 7 à 9 dollars
lui avait dit on va l'indexer pour pas
pour éviter un choc tarifaire pour les
familles Michel promesse rompu
oui évidemment promesse rompu promesse
qui aurait jamais dû être faite
d'ailleurs parce qu'au moment où cette
augmentation là avait été annoncée ça
avait très bien passer tout le monde
s'est demandé qu'est-ce qu'il avait
piquer les libéraux pour que tout d'un
coup ils veulent revenir là-dessus euh
mais maintenant tout le monde sera
d'accord pour que les garderies soient
gratuites puis que ça soit comme ça
jusqu'à l'université he dans un monde
idéal ce serait ça mais je pense qu'il
faut mettre vraiment les choses en
perspective quand le régime a été créé
en 98 l'usager payait 20 % de la note
l'état payait le reste aujourd'hui la
part de l'usager est à 13 %. autrement
dit toute proportion gardé ça coûte
moins cher aujourd'hui d'envoyer ses
enfants à la garderie que ça coûtait il
y a 15 ans alors que il est évident que
les finances publiques ne sont pas
celles qu'elles étaient il y a 15 ans
alors à partir de ce moment-là il est
évident que c'est désagréable d'avoir
une hausse comme celle-là c'est un choc
pour certains mais si on avait indexé
les tarifs à l'inflation dès le départ
on n serait pas là aujourd'hui alors
tout tous les gouvernements successifs
ont été lâche là-dessus ou à laaveille
des élections on promet ça en se disant
bon ben on verra mais c'est un programme
dont les Québécois sont très fiers avec
raison mais c'est un programme qui coûte
cher Tcha quand même il y a des jeunes
familles qui se sentent peut-être
trahies aujourd'hui
peut-être mais mon dieu je suis d'accord
avec Michel écoute c'est je crois que
passeil vous êes parlé avant ou non pas
du tout je suis surprise Michel mais
mais honnêtement je pense si si on est
honnête avec soi-même c'est vrai si
l'indexation si les gouvernements
auraient eu le courage politique
d'indexer on serait pas ici parce que le
tarif serait déjà plus plus haut serait
au aux alentours de 20 % ce qu'il serait
selon la réforme Couillard est-ce que
c'est c'est une promesse brisée
certaines familles vont dire oui et dans
le sens pur é mais je pense que Monsieur
card il a dit
aujourd'hui la l'universalité ne veut
pas nécessairement dire maintenir un
cout fixe pour tout le monde c'est la
capacité d'avoir accès à un programme
selon le revenu et je pense
l'augmentation ne touche pas la vaste
majorité d'une façon exigeante de la
population alors je pense que c'est
c'est le gros bon sens écoute en Ontario
s avait un programme comme ça les gens
danseraient dans la rue alors voilà oui
c'est vrai que c'est probablement le
c'est le program le plus généreux en
Ontario parce que j'y habite comme tacha
mes voisins qui ont 3 enfants à la
garderie payent 60 dollars par jour par
enfant 18 dollars par jour ça c'est la
moyenne alors non seulement il danserait
dans la rue mais il écrirait au Père
Noël tout de suite et il serait très
content donc le programme fait l'envie
du reste du pays n'empêche Philippe
Couillard dit que le programme nétait
plus soutenable tel qu'el qu'en modulant
les tarif il le préserve donc c un
programme envier mais trop coûteux trop
luxueux pour le Québec 2 7 milliards de
dollars est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est trop coûteux plusieurs vous diront
oui Michel a fait la démonstration tout
à l'heure que les parents payaient de
moins en moins et l'état de plus en plus
vous savez quand vous vous lancez dans
une vaste opération d'assaainissement
des finances publiques comme le fait le
gouvernement Couillard en ce moment il
ne peut pas y avoir de vaches sacrées je
suis convaincu qu'on touchera pas au
frais de scolarité pour les raisons que
vous connaissez à cause de la réaction
qu'on a eu il y a il y a il y a 18 mois
2 ans mais tous les autres programmes on
le voit l'éducation on le voit dans le
domaine de la santé on est en train
d'effectuer une grande opération
d'assainissement des finances publiques
est-ce qu'on aurait dû épargner les
garderies à écoutez oui c'est un
excellent programme oui ça a permis à
plusieurs femmes de retourner sur le
marché du travail d'avoir des carrières
je regardais tout à l'heure les chiffres
il y a pas plus de femmes qui
travaillent au Québec qui en a moins
qu'en Alberta moins qu'en Ontario moins
qu'en sascat Chan alors oui le programme
est bon et c'est pas la panassée
universelle non plus n'empêche que déjà
on l' commencé à l'entendre quand même
on s'attaque à l'univers
fais ou on s'attaque à l'universalité
mais l'universalité il y a un myth
là-dedans il y a beaucoup d'entorse déjà
à l'universalité prenez par exemple dans
les CHSLD hein les personnes âgées le
tarif est selon le revenu alors pourquoi
quand on est âgé ça serait comme ça mais
quand on est ENF ça le serait pas et et
même dans le système de garde voyez les
gens qui envoient leurs enfants dans des
garderies non subventionné parce qu'il y
a pas de place dans les garderies
subventionnées bah le crédit d'impôt
qu'ils ont en retour n'a pas la même
valeur selon qu'ils ont des revenus plus
ou moins élevés alors là déjà il y a une
progressivité si on veut qui existe au
moment où on se parle et ettant que
l'universalité le principe même voyez il
y avait un sondage beaucoup de gens ont
été surpris moi en tout cas la semaine
dernière oui c'est un Léger Marketing du
devoir et 60 % des Québécois se disaient
d'accord avec la modulation selon de
revenu et et et de tous les partis enfin
il a Québec solidaire il y avait
simplement 46 % qui étaient d'accord ce
qui est beaucoup quand on voit les cris
d'indignation qui sont poussés par leur
porte-parole mais les pquistes les
caquistes évidemment les libéraux tous
ces gens-là était largement d'accord
avec le principe tacha
donc pour une famille moyenne quand même
qui gagne un revenu familial le 120000
dollars c'est 1500 dollars de plus par
enfant c'est pas rien quand même c'est
pas rien mais écoute compte contre ça
cette familleel va recevoir 60 dollars
par enfant de plus du gouvern fédéral et
ils vont recevoir une hausse du de du de
la
déductibilité
des c'est ça crédit d'impôt pour pour
les frais de garde de 1000 de 1000
dollars de plus par enfant alors là
qu'est-ce qu'on arrive c'est presque la
totalité par enfant du 1500 ça va pas
leur frapper autant que ça c'est sûr
qu'ils vont pas bénéficier de cet argent
en su de ce qu'ils ont présentement mais
c'est très intéressant de voir cette
réforme qui arrive en même temps que le
gouvernement fédéral qui ont dit écoute
on va vous aider avec votre choix
finalement euh écoute c'est un choix de
société que le Québec a fait d'avoir un
programme comme cela mais il faut qu'il
se finance d'une façon responsable
autrement ça peut pas être soutenable
mais est-ce que ça ouvre la porte
maintenant parce que les gens vont se
poser des questions à a d'autres
modulations pour d'autres choses Daniel
ou plus que la modulation encore est-ce
que comme le disait François zavid
aujourd'hui on s'en va vers le principe
utilisateur payeur est-ce que est-ce
qu'à partir de maintenant tous les
services que vous allez avoir du
gouvernement vous allez payer
plus si vous êtes riche moins si vous
êtes pas riche est-ce que est-ce que on
va aller si s'il faut se rendre jusque
là et que l'assaainissement on narrive
pas on n arrive pas à à un ticket
modérateur en santé à des payages
partout sur les autoroutes c'est quoi la
solution si vous n'êtes pas capable
d'assignir les finances publiques et que
vous êtes menacé de décotte ou de quoi
que ce soit al je vous dis pas que c'est
vers ça qu'on s'en va mais le le ce qui
est arrivé avec les garderies
aujourd'hui ça ouvre la porte à d'autres
possibilités dépendment de l'acceptabil
C avait déjà recommandé un ticket
modérateur et en très page ça déjàé
discuté aussi je pense qu'il faut être
ouvert à ces solutions là
particulièrement quand il y a une dette
fulgurante comme le Québec
comparativement aux autres provinces qui
eu ont aussi parfois des des coûts on
peut passenser à l'autoroute 407 ici à
Ontario qui est privé les gens payent
pour ça c'est leur choix de le faire
écoute il y a des options mais comme
j'ai dit il faut tous les explorer alors
élargissons un peu le débat parce qu'il
y avait un sondage publié aujourd'hui
dans lequel on voyait une certaine
montée satisfaction vis-à-vis du
gouvernement Couillard le sondard
parlait même d'une cassure alors comment
vous expliquez ça Michel moi je trouve
qu'assû c'est un peu fort là dans la
mesure où s'il y avait des élections
demain matin le gouvernement Couillard
serait reconduit elles ont lieu juste
dans 4 ans vous voyez exactement mais
euh bon il il y a de la satisfaction ça
ça va de soi euh moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est c'est c'est pas tellement à
cause ben sûrement pas simplement à
cause de de l'histoire des garderies
mais c'est le sentiment général h c'est
le sentiment général d'avoir été Tromp
les libéraux il av promis qu'urait pas
d'augmentation Auel de l'inflation
cétait la même chose pour les tarifs
d'hydroquébec c'était la même chose pour
la taxe scolaire alors que là P temp s
factures dans la cour des commissions
scolaires sont obligé de d'augmenter la
taxe alors tout
ça et voilà et la grande promesse
c'était de dire ne vous inquiétez pas
avec quand on va arriver au pouvoir il
va avir un espèce d'effet magique là qui
va dauper l'économie et cette
croissance-l va absorber une grande
partie des compressions et on le voit
c'est pas le cas ouais quand quand vous
êtes en campagne électorale et que vous
promettez aux gens d'assignir les
finances publiques tout le monde est
pour la vertu tout le monde aime la
tarte ou pas disent oui oui oui bravo
merci bonjour mais quand vous réalisez
qu'on coupe bon nombre de commissions
scolaires qu'on refait complètement le
système de santé qu'on change le
financement des garderies et quoi encore
il y a il y a plusieurs mesures qui ont
été annoncées ou lancées là les gens se
disent
est-ce que c'est vraiment pour ça qu'on
a voté est-ce que c'est c'est vraiment
ça qu'on veut est-ce que le Québec est
rendu là est-ce qu'on devrait pas
peut-être avoir un grand débat de
société làdessus décider exactement où
on veut couper
euh vaut mieux que ça arrive au
gouvernement Couillard en début de
mandat et il vaut mieux pour lui qu'il
réussisse son son opération
d'assainissement des finances public
parce que là les gens vont lu voir mais
il vaudrait mieux aussi éventuellement
introduire il y a cette idée d'avoir
comme d'ailleurs un espèce de de
directeur parlementaire du budget qui
donnerait à la veille d'une élection un
portrait exact des finances publiques
parce que là c'est c'est tout le ça
marche pas
Michel je sais pas ça marche pas bien
wa gouvernement un peu l'aime pas
beaucoup mais exactement le gouvernement
conservateur l'a créé à
Otawa ça marche pas du tout ça fait pas
du tout leur AFF mais du point de vue
d'un contribuable je pense que ça serait
plus honnête à la veille d'une élection
d'avoir un portrait exact bon on va
rester à l'Assemblée nationale pour dire
un mot en terminant sur pierre-carle
péado j'aurais préféré attendre qu'il se
présente pour qu'on en parle de façon
va se présenter ben je sais pas mais
c'est ce qu'on nous dit mais on a
l'impression qu'il apprend le métier de
député à la dure non cette semaine
c'était des problèmes avec la presse
c'est très dur pour Monsieur P vous
savez Jean Charret disait un politicien
qui se plaint des médias c'est comme un
poisson qui se plaint de l'eau c'est il
se plaint de son environnement c'est
tout ce qui est arrivé à Monsieur Pado
cette semaine c'est c'est des choses
tout à fait normales recevoir un appel
sur son cellulaire ça faire ost par
journale se faire accoster dans un
couloir du Parlement écoutez c'est c'est
l'é de la vie de c'est le quotidien d'un
politicien alors un moment donné
monsieur péado devra comprendre qu'il
n'est pas l'empereur de Chine qu' peut
pas décider de de revoir toutes les
règles de la démocratie québécoise comme
elles existent depuis des dizaines
d'années vous savez monsieur péado
pendant le l au Journal de Montréal il
avait poursuivi le président de
l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'il était
pas capable de faire créditer ses scabes
à la tribune de la presse ben il y a des
règles et puis monsieur péado vous être
obligé de s plier comme tout le monde
c'est justement Michel Michel tu as dit
le mot démocratie monsieur péado c'est
un homme d'affaires qui devrait
connaître les médias d'ailleurs c'est
son métier mais quand même c'est pas une
personne qui a dû respecter les opinions
de de plein de monde comme la population
comme les autres politiciens alors
s'habituer à ça je pense il a un peu de
difficulté mais il y a plusieurs modèles
qui pourrai suivre BR mais beaucoup de
journalistes répondent tout le temps Rud
répond à 9 questions sur 10 refusit de
répondre à 9/ 10 et Stepen Harper refuse
de répondre à 10/ 10 alors il y a
plusieurs modèles dont il peut
s'inspirer he pour fonctionner avec des
journalistes au Québec c'est c'est assez
différent honnêtement même des hommes
comme Monsieur Pariso monsieur Bouchard
qui était pas des gens qui se laissaient
manger la laine sur le dos facilement
c'était plié d'assz bonne grâce et
paradoxalement celui qui a le plus mal
vécu je pense avec ça céit un autre
patron de presse Ctait Claude Ryan quand
monsieur Ryan était chef du Parti
libéral les relations étaient très avec
la presse alors il faut un journaliste
comme Ren levque et pas un patron comme
Monsieur
péado ch très juste en tout cas monsieur
péado trouve le moyen de faire parler de
lui toutes les semaines même s'il est
pas encore candidat on s'en reparlera
merci beaucoup à vous trois au revoiroir